I don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about dude your taco was black
with a capital H Wow and I love Gordon
Ramsay - this is weird phase two where
people are going I don't know how I feel
about this and I want to know your
opinion on this
yeah always fine I get a white guilt the
funniest thing to me because it's I know
somebody that posts every other it's the
story post is about how white people
should repent for their sins and he's
like the whitest [ __ ] I've ever
met in my life
and he's quoting like Martin Luther King
everybody
yeah and he's trying to make white
people feel as bad as possible for being
white and for me when I see that I'm
just like man you're doing too much bro
you wanna be on this side over here but
you ain't hate yourself he hates his
skin like I think he hates himself like
he wakes up and he's like yeah he goes
[ __ ] you and your pale ass skin dude you
and your white privilege and then he
goes and starts whipping himself [ __ ]
I'll show you his post he's a really
cool dude I love to do it a lot but I
started looking at his post I was like
damn bro you really hate me white boy as
black people we're not asking that yeah
like I think a lot of times all we want
is like the mere acknowledgment mm-hmm
like bro just oh you don't have to
obviously you you know because we like I
didn't own slaves obviously you you
personally didn't own slaves and maybe
your family didn't either but that
doesn't mean you don't reap the benefit
yeah of white people like I feel like I
was talking about this this is a really
interesting examiner key yeah okay so
the motorcycle show if you guys don't
know about it motorcycle show about
white bikers and they commit crimes do
all this stuff right so I remember like
out the show went up I was driving up to
four or five and I saw like a group of
bikers all right man they're probably
gonna go sell some drugs or guns and I
was like dang why would I think that
like I don't know these guys yeah and I
realized the media is the reason I
thought that because I watched that show
now take that to black people and how
many times on the news you've seen black
drug dealers and black people parade
across your screen and and they're thugs
all the way back to slavery like they
want to rape our white women that's what
these black people want to do when in
fact it was really white slave masters
who were
raping black women but they flipped it
around and made people scared of black
people so now you have that bias that
you don't even realize you've been
internalizing your whole life if you're
not black you like men then people are
probably scared so even black people
sometimes you see black people coming
with the hoodie allow any lock my door
yeah because so many times you're afraid
of big black guy in hoodie he's menacing
like that stuff happens to me all the
time we're in stores people follow us
around all that type of stuff you
realize like part of that isn't you
personally but it's you being a part of
society in society's painting black
people especially black men one way all
the time you internalize that and even
realize that there's a huge example of
that where I talked about it earlier in
the podcast is when I first started my
best friend he's Rwandan big all black
do six foot one mmm we took this picture
in a bar right it was me it was his
cousin's right so to hero get a go Gobbo
and me and then one of his other buddies
was a he's a neurosurgeon mmm and we
just took a picture cuz I haven't seen
these guys in a minute and they're like
family work together in Sacramento yeah
we took a big photo and then you know
one of the top comments was Davis trying
to get his his hood car and I'm like
hood card like his these two dudes her
mom is the ambassador for Rwanda he's a
doctor and that's a neurosurgeon yeah
but they're black though yeah they're
probably from the hood and nothing about
what they were wearing anything about
hood shape and they kind of clicked in
my head I was like oh that's interesting
you know I'm not trying to be on some
walk [ __ ] but for me I'm like I'm in
that group of picture on the piece of
[ __ ] so I'm standing here like damn I
deserve to be in this photo when you see
that I guess image wise I guess for
people who didn't grow up around black
people it's more like that's the the
stuff that they're fed absolutely so for
them what they see is oh he's trying to
he's trying to up his hood Carlos a
little bit card these are [ __ ]
physician absolutely ma'am but you
wouldn't think that yeah that's not the
first thing you think it's funny cuz
weed tours comedians me Tony
Doughboy into here right so people I
can't even tell you how many times why
people would see us in the airport or
restaurant either are you guys football
players like look at my body do I look
like a professional athlete are you guys
in the NBA the NBA
is 300 pounds what about us looks like
we are professional athletes we can't
figure it out what are you guys doing on
the plane
and so I'm Diamond on Delta so I'm
always in first class why don't be like
this is the first class line yes you
know that's why I'm standing in it yeah
because I'm flying first class and I
mean all right get on it this time oh I
didn't know cuz you just assumed that
you shouldn't be here and that's the
thing about why people like your people
are like my all why people racist that's
not true yeah right but what happens is
a lot of people are okay with you doing
whatever you do as long as it makes
sense that you should be doing it but
you can fly on the plane but you
shouldn't be in first class yeah that's
where do you but it and it usually is
mostly white people so when people are
doing stuff out of the ordinary that's
when it feels weird the whole Trayvon
Martin things like well that you why are
you walking with a hoodie in this
neighborhood you don't belong here and
that's what it is it's it's the why
people feel there's this whole article I
was going viral like have you ever the
title is have you ever noticed why
people never move out your way like on
the street and it was like all these
people like yeah like it's like I should
I belong here and I'm gonna walk and if
you were in my way then you should move
and a lot of this stuff is subconscious
because you know to be white is to feel
like you belong here
many people shuttles on your way my
friend told me that the annoying thing
about me he goes new and then most and
this is when I was in Sacramento yeah
whenever you see a white person on the
sidewalk he goes you purposely don't
move out their way right you don't I
don't because of that [ __ ] yeah because
I always had to move out of their way
yes that's so [ __ ] funny you said
that you just had that conversation last
week goes he goes I know for a fact when
we walk on a sidewalk we're not the ones
moving out the way cuz you refuse I was
like I refuse right cuz why do I not
always do it why people will go ahead
and we think it's polite yeah but you're
kind of trained to like well you know
let me just get out the way and a lot of
times and it's fine if everybody does
that but this group of people they don't
seem to play by those rules as much as
everybody else does yeah and they don't
even realize it a lot of times like I
didn't even know like yeah minorities we
be knowing why people better than they
know
and that's why I hate the whole like go
back to your country thing yeah people
say to minorities because I feel like
minorities love America more because we
see it for what it really is yeah it's
not the same for everybody else so the
fact that we love it and we criticize it
comes from a place of love not we want
to leave and may you brought us here
religion dance isn't freaking Egypt you
saw we did leave us alone
it's crazy go back I've never been there
go back to your country it's like they
don't want us there here they don't
[ __ ] people hate people rah for real
though I don't religion no they do not
rock with African American AZ muddy
focus exactly yeah they over here in
this country they think that they could
do whatever they want exactly not
playing around
yes I this conversation with my friend
Amina she was telling me like when she
first came here like she heard a lot of
stuff about kind of the stereotypes with
black people there and maybe for her and
maybe it's cuz her parents that are that
stuff too she goes yeah I don't
understand what the big deal but they
don't know about system at assistant I
systemic like oppression it's not they
just see a lazy person we ready go wool
cuz African people from what I've heard
from African friends in mind they
consider themselves immigrants not black
people right we're immigrants yes you
know and we had that immigrant hustler
mentality absolutely and a lot of times
they do yeah because when you come from
another country to America you've left
everything behind like I gotta make it
and that hustle is not over there we
were talking about this off-camera like
people who come to LA to make it often
work harder than people who are born and
raised in LA because they can always go
into mom's house and their cousin stuff
if you ain't from here it's either make
it or you got to go back home you and a
lot of times you get like when I moved
here I rented my house out in Washington
my parents lived in North Carolina full
house like it's either make it here or
no plan B like you gotta make it so that
hustle mentality is even two or three
times